in this video we shall rank the top 20
most powerful titans in the monster
verse
after taking into consideration all the
movies up till godzilla vs kong
and even the most recent comics so strap
yourselves up and decide if our pick
matches yours so before we go on do not
forget to smash that subscribe button to
be a part of the mind cue family
so now let's get down with this sickness
number 20 the skull crawler on the leads
of this list are the skull crawlers
which are tough
with the ability to withstand bullets
and the scorching fire of a flame
thrower kong rammed the big one's head
with a tree
and it was just dazed while another
skrull crawler
it could withstand fire from a 50
caliber machine gun
although even the big one can do that
although more powerful the big one in
godzilla vs kong was killed without even
a struggle
which puts it at the last of this list
number 19 narkika titanos nakika is a
large cephalopod
titan that looks more like an octopus or
a squid and has a thick
curving shell that covers its massive
brain its blood is green
in battle nakika uses its tentacles
which
are capable of shattering bulletproof
glass and taking down an entire monarch
platform
it was still trapped though later on and
captured by monarch
which means it wasn't as powerful
number 18 the muto male the male mutual
can unleash an electromagnetic pulse
from its claws which can disable
electric apparatus within a 5 mile
radius
and has wings that can use to fly the
male muto was strong enough to drag
godzilla away from the female
and it also fought godzilla for several
hours by himself
from the afternoon and well into the
night although it was more of a game of
attack you're it kind of fight
number 17 cilla seen first and king of
the monster
cilla was a beast due to the spiky armor
that covers her body and legs
cell is durable enough to topple
buildings and withstand bullets and
missiles with little to no damage
silla's legs and her spiky tips are
strong enough to tear through
solid rock and buildings with ease but
it was easily defeated by godzilla with
a kick
in godzilla dominion comics
number 16 the muto female immutos are
durable enough to take barrages of both
small and large arms fire without any
damage
the female was able to claw herself out
as well as being
able to destroy buildings with ease she
was also able to toss and ram godzilla
around
despite his immense size and weight it
is highly underestimated but it's quite
powerful nonetheless
number 15 behemoth although we thought
behemoth was a monster to be feared and
one of the most powerful
but it was only his size and the fact
that it was destroying buildings that
made us feel that way
it was in fact a general giant and was
beaten in a fight with amhuluk
but it did manage to get a couple of
blows and hits before it was thrown down
into the amazon
but it was saved later by the big g
number 14 methuselah next on this list
is this mountain of a titan
literally since methuselah's back is
partly made of rock
it is incredibly strong allowing it to
withstand powerful attacks
methuselah can cause a great deal of
harm and damage and destruction with his
strong
jaws and huge horns he can even bear an
entire human population on his back with
ease
number 13 amhulu this is a massive
demonic looking mammalian titan
looking like an evil tree beard from the
love of the rings
being black in coloration with 10 yellow
eyes and black pupils
it is a hostile titan that is willing to
kill others in order to claim their
territory however he fears and respects
godzilla but that
doesn't mean it won't beat the crap out
of other titans like behemoth
number 12 the queen muto next is an
upgraded version of the muto female
the queen muto seems to lack the
malicious streaks that the prime and the
muto couple had
godzilla and a six-legged muto queen
seemed to have a respectful relationship
and she bowed down to him
but she has been through a lot in her
life which means that she has survived
gojira species more than once even
though they are rivals
number 11 shinomura the shinomura is a
conglomerate of millions of smaller
creatures
merged to create one single entity much
like destroyer
it feeds on radiation and if large
enough is capable of dragging godzilla
around
shinomura can shape its combined form in
any way it wants to
and thanks to its composite construction
it allows
it to add extra appendages like
tentacles and even take on smaller
shapes
number 10 tiamat tiamat greatly
resembles a giant serpentine leafy
sea dragon with crocodile-like jaws her
scales are purple while her fins are
blue in color
she appears as a rival titan who fights
godzilla shortly after she took over one
of the latter's
old layers after a short yet intense
battle
godzilla manages to overcome tiamat but
she did manage to get an advantage over
him underwater
which is kinda rare number nine warbat
wabats are reptilian serpentine titans
that are grayish in color and have
two red membranous wings that extend
down from the top half of their bodies
warbats are subterranean apex predators
and that live in the hollow earth
rainforest
their long serpentine bodies are capable
of grappling and subduing titans like
kong
almost strangling him to death number
eight
camazotz this is a massive gray-colored
bat like titan with demonic horns and
facial features
as well as large dotted wings covered in
long sharp spikes
camazot's primary weapons are its teeth
claws and wings
and also his tail he is not really
strong enough to lift gong up before
dropping him hundreds of feet
from the air it wanted to be an alpha
and almost had its way with gong
number 7 rodon rodan appears to be an
overall neutral titan whose allegiances
goes only to whichever titan beats it or
currently occupies the alpha position
it is one of the only three titans that
had the guts to fight monster zero
it is biovolcanic and can fly at
supersonic speeds and was also super
durable
able to even come back after being
stabbed in the heart
by matra number six mothra
although she looks fragile mothra isn't
the queen of the monsters for nothing
she was another titan that fought
against ghidorah and was evenly matched
against rodan in their aerial duel
and even though she was nearly pinned by
the fire demon she did manage to win by
stabbing him with her stinger
right through the heart number 5
gong now we come to the realm of the
actual alpha titans of the monsterverse
and kong is the least on this list which
means
that even though he is that powerful
there are even more powerful ones than
him
the giant a boas of no special abilities
but his intelligence
and his brute strength as well as
tactical usage of the environment
he did manage to knock out godzilla in
one of the bells
number four the muto prime after the two
mutos and
queen muto the mute prime comes as the
top of their species transformations
throughout her life mutual prime had
killed several members of titanos gujera
no easy feat for any titan she was even
faster than godzilla while swimming
underwater
and she nearly killed him if not for the
intervention of emma
activating a device that makes sonic
pulses distracting her and allowing
godzilla to kill her instead
number 3 ghidorah now we come to the top
of the food chain
but it's not from this world it is
clearly more powerful than godzilla in
battle
managing to drop him off from the upper
atmosphere and also sucking his
radiation almost killing the big g
it can regenerate and is practically
immortal
even after its body is vaporized by
burning godzilla as it can live on in
mecca godzilla
number 2 mecha godzilla unlike its
previous incarnations this mechagodzilla
has
enhanced physical strength and
human-like reflexes that allowed it to
effortlessly
overpower an adult skull crawler as well
as knock over
and throw godzilla around like a rag
doll it also has
a proton scream beam and the spiral heat
ray that beats godzilla's atomic breath
and it should have been on rank number
one if not for one little thing
and number one godzilla the big g
the king of the monsters yes i know it
was nearly killed by muto prime
knocked out by kong nearly sucked the
life out by monster zero and thrown
around like a ragdoll by mecha godzilla
but this is the little thing that i just
said it is still on the number one spot
because of its transformation in king of
the monsters
as burning godzilla he was opie
overpowered and was practically
indestructible and would be able to
defeat
any of the titans effortlessly
so that's that the top 20 most powerful
talents of the monsterverse
anyway it's been a blast and we have
come to the end of this video
do hit that like button for support and
subscribe to be a part of the mind cue
family
and also smash that bell button for
regular updates on master videos
right here on minecube take care fam